[music playing]
No single tool in
the human arsenal
explains our existence
more than fire.
One of the things we
talk about in the show
is that on the one hand,
fire is one of the most
destructive forces, right?
Like you can cook your
food on the one hand,
but you can also like
burn your village.
Early humans quickly
discovered that fire
was a very destructive force.
At the same time, however, when
domesticated, when harnessed,
it eventually would lead us
to power our jet engines,
you know, controlled
explosions even in a car
is what makes engines work.
And so it's this capacity that
human beings have to harness,
to creatively harness
potentially destructive forces
and use them towards creative
ends that I think is amazing.
[explosion]
We are a fire species.
And these are the stories
that have made us human.
This is our evolution,
the never-ending journey.
We have only our past to help
us navigate and face our future.
[music playing]